[Música]
ustedes creen que los nacimientos son
mejores
hace 28 años que soy partera he
acompañado a casi 10.000 familias al
nacimiento de sus hijos
seguramente a muchos de los que están
acá los debo haber acompañado
y no a todos los atendí por igual
una de las cosas que hizo que los
nacimientos sean mejores es que nosotros
los profesionales cambiamos
y otra de las cosas es la madre que hoy
la madre se ocupa del parto se prepara
y está acompañada
algo que es muy importante que la madre
hoy se acompañara
todo eso me da la certeza para decir que
los partos y los nacimientos hoy cada
vez son mejores
a veces escucho que le preguntan a una
mamá
cuántos hijos tenéis la mamá dice dos le
pregunta inmediatamente fue parto
cesárea
la mamá esposa cesárea
como sea con culpa y al inmediatamente
justifica porque le hicieron necesaria
como si eso nos definiera como si tener
un hijo por parto por cesárea haría que
uno fuera más madre o menos madre
si nosotros entendiéramos que nosotros
somos madres desde el momento que nos
enteramos que estamos embarazada
y cada cambio corporal y cada cuidado
que cada emoción y cada miedo hace que
nosotros desde ese momento lo empezamos
a parir
si nosotros entendemos eso los
nacimientos van a ser mejores
yo me encuentro con las parejas más o
menos a los 7 meses
su trabajo en equipo con un obstetra y
cuando siga a la pareja
si al medios serios no nos conocemos
y lo primero que me dicen con un tono
adriana nosotros queremos un parto
respetado
obvio que van a tener un pacto de
respeto no digo nada me su orgullo
y empezamos a charlar al cuarto yo les
pregunto a ellos
ustedes que quieren tener un hijo o
tener un parto
y ahí ellos
si son muy bien
y ahí parece que nos empezamos a
entender
y ahí empezamos a transitar un camino
para el nacimiento de nuestros hijos
una noche a las 4 de la mañana
suena el teléfono a la madrugada me
cuesta ver quién es que me llama por
teléfono y un padre me llama gritando
adriana tiene martina viene martina
llegó martín a su entendía nada hasta
que me ubique quién era
me contagió la alegría y quedamos en
encontrarnos en el sanatorio cuando
lleva el sanatorio
esta hora ha sido con su señora él tenía
una cara de feliz cumpleaños increíbles
ella es lo que ella estaba cansada
ojerosa
y empezamos a acompañar en el trabajo
porque parís es natural pero no es fácil
saben cómo se llama lo previo el trabajo
al palpar y trabajo de parto porque la
mamá tiene que hacer un trabajo enorme
físico mental y emocional
uno cuando va a parir se va a encontrar
con la fuerza de la naturaleza
parir es informarse que esa información
no se empodere
parís encontrarse con el dolor
dolor porque el parto duele les podría
decir otra palabra pero el parto duele
pero nos encontramos con el dolor desde
otro lugar
el parto duele tanto muchas veces los
pacientes me preguntan adrián hasta
cuánto me va a doler y yo le digo y
hasta que no des más y me mira con cada
como pensaban que debilidades y de otra
cosa
duele tanto que la mamá en el trabajo de
parto
esboza la palabra me muero
me muera en el instante que va a dar
vida
y ahí aparece que nos acompaña
que el papá o la pareja o una persona
que nos acompañe emocionalmente
acompaña en todo el proceso sabe
proyecto a esa mamá la mira la impondrá
la gira de energía y solo con una mirada
con tocarla y logran que esta mamá
llegue al final
cuando me llamo horacio con esa alegría
en ese momento se pone el manifiesto
todo lo que los padres sienten en el
nacimiento de sus hijos nosotros ponemos
todo el foco en la mamá pero es muy
importante lo que siente esa persona que
nos acompaña
para ir también es perder el control
una vez un papá
me había dicho adriana yo no voy a pasar
el parto
fue el curso no nos acompaña en el curso
todo
y ya lo habíamos trabajado con la con la
mamá bueno perfecto me llamó un día por
teléfono me dice era el mediodía y me
dice
adriana vamos al sanatorio porque a
marina le duele mucho la espalda
bueno bárbaro 9 en la espalda dijo
sigo al sanatorio y cuando llego a
marina estaba así
pálido generosa cansada ayer las llamas
que tiene a espaldas y me dice yo duele
mucho la espalda quiere hacer fuerza no
sale nada y no se gana no sé qué pasa
cuando la vi y yo me di cuenta que
estaba pariendo
entonces le digo bueno
acostarte maría marín a que te voy a
evaluar la costa mos cuando el evalúo
estaba pariendo literalmente estaba
pariendo y no había tiempo para ir a la
sala de partos y nada
entonces lo miro al marido y le digo me
ayudas sí sí me dijo por supuesto es más
yo
entonces él dijo bueno tomarle la mano
y la vida marina le digo bueno marina
ahora vas a hacer fuerza y van a ser tu
bebé
el marido miró con cara como yo en la
este
bueno marina hizo fuerza y nació su bebé
un bebé hermoso
si lo hicimos en el pecho salimos de la
habitación
y a la media hora me llegó un mensaje
qué me dice adrián agradezco a la vida y
me haya puesto en este lugar porque si
yo lo pensaba me perdería esta
maravillosa experiencia
también a veces tenemos que aceptar que
nosotros tenemos un proyecto del par al
nacimiento de nuestros hijos y se puede
cambiar el camino y haya que hacer una
cesárea para eso también nos tenemos que
preparar
nosotros nos tenemos que preparar para
tener un hijo no importa si es parto
cesárea nosotros nos estamos preparando
para tener un hijo hace poco viene una
pareja a que iban a tener cesárea
porque él estaba de cola y la forma más
segura para que nazca se deberá una
cesárea
en una fiesta llegaron felices el papá
de la compañía al quirófano salió del
quirófano y cuando lo voy a buscar el
papá para acompañarlo a la habitación él
estaba con su hija
si la apoya en la cara
y le susurraba en el oído no sabes lo
que te estaba esperando maría emilia
ahí sentí que esa pareja había entendido
todo porque esa pareja había trabajado
para tener un hijo no importaba como
había sido
por eso yo los invito a todos a todas
las mujeres que van a tener hijos a
todos los papás
que se preparen y se ocupen para su
parto que gusten gente que los acompañe
en este proyecto que ustedes quieren
porque es el momento más feliz de sus
vidas y lo tienen que disfrutar así
tener un hijo te atraviesa te atraviesa
el alma
y nosotros tenemos que ocuparnos de que
eso sea el momento más feliz
y aparte nos vamos a encontrar con el
amor más puro
más verdadero y más incondicional yo
encontré el mío muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]